two good bits of climate news from the
un general assembly this week for us to
discuss
joe biden as expected upping the united
states commitment to funding climate
action in the developing world and then
in more of a surprise move xi jinping
saying that china would no longer
finance coal projects abroad and with
just 40 days to go before cop 26 in
glasgow we're going to be asking is this
a turning point so tom i want to ask you
first of all about these big
announcements let's focus in on china
because i'm going to show everybody what
the un uh secretary general antonio
gutierrez has said about the issue of
coal he said accelerating the global
phase out of coal is the single most
important step in keeping the paris
agreements key warning limit within
reach so this announcement by china is
it a key breakthrough ahead of cop26
i don't know that it's it's quite a
breakthrough but it's certainly a very
important development and it it more so
because it was a bit unexpected and i
think that's helped to change the tone
of the conversation as we run in it was
getting to be a bit gloomy and and now i
think together with the biden
announcement this announcement
particularly because of as the secretary
general was saying how important coal is
i think this has lifted the tone and
begun to put a little bit of momentum
into it but i think it's a bit early to
say it's an actual breakthrough okay so
to make it a breakthrough would china
have to say we're going to make the same
announcement as far as our domestic coal
production is concerned because they
rely so much on it in the country don't
they
i think that's exactly right as tom uh
showed us just a minute ago i think that
would that really would be a
breakthrough if they were to make the
commitment to phase out coal with a
deadline uh a little bit before 2060
then i think we'd really be looking at
something you could count as a
breakthrough okay michaela that's china
let's talk about president biden's
announcement as well on climate finance
doubling finance to uh developing
countries uh to 11 billion dollars i
mean climate finance has been a big
sticking point so does this give you
some sense of positivity that climate
justice can be achieved at cop
that's a really good question um
i think when it comes to the united
states i am quite hesitant about um
celebrating a kind of a move from
climate denial to climate delay because
what we actually need is climate action
and both climate denial and climate
today give us an unlivable future and
what we actually need is a livable
future and that means
moving beyond this kind of bare minimum
they still haven't met the 100 billion
um target they need for this climate and
fund and actually that's not even enough
i think if you consider how much of a
part to play the united states and
countries like the uk have had in the
creation of this crisis and continuing
to perpetuate so many emissions i think
what we actually need to hear in cop26
is how um all of these nations listening
to the countries that are most affected
and the people who are most effective
and indigenous leaders and all these
people and listening to what climate
justice means for those people rather
than almost passing themselves on the
back for doing what i see is almost less
than the bare minimum
and where does this leave us do you
think then tom i mean cop 21 the paris
agreement was reached it was
deemed a huge success could the same
happen for [ __ ] 26 in november
i think you need a different uh a kind
of different measure of success what
paris was about was really trying to put
together a global agreement to deal with
the problem i think what we're now
looking at are the steps we have to take
to implement that agreement and this is
a really important one of those steps
and i think michaela's right to be a
little bit cautious about what the
americans are saying about money it's
not the president of the united states
that decides how much money america can
give but u.s congress and that's a
little bit less focused on climate
justice than the president is okay so so
i think that that we mustn't raise our
expectations too high uh for the cop i
think it's
some real progress being made in the
last few days i think we've got to see
some more uh in the interim period
between now and the cop itself so we
need to be looking at the g20 meeting uh
next month very briefly michaela can cop
26 be a success does this bode well
um i think that's yeah that's also a
difficult question because i think
considering how many nations aren't even
able to make it to the cop how many
indigenous leaders how many of the most
affected people and countries aren't
being able to make it there i find it
difficult to know whether this will be
the success that um maybe we need it to
be um it seems especially from what
boris johnson is saying almost
applauding himself and then using water
baptism and talking about china and
india rather than the uk's huge
emissions and their investment in fossil
fuels and it's going to be almost like
all of these countries coming together
to talk about how great they are rather
than actually addressing the real harm
that's being caused